[Applaudissements]
le brave au chef était ou folle
ah oui alors donc moyens mais c'est vrai
après je ne veux pas de méchants t1
jeudi côté l'état elle ça qu'elles
représentent tous moi j'aime beaucoup
vraiment alors et enfin gérard gillmann
et avec qui vous n'êtes détesteriez
partis en vacances avec vous pour voir
s'il ya risque que vous êtes arena
phobique vient vous êtes arena phobique
henry la phobie qui s'avère que j'aime
pas les maillots arena sarah van grieken
mai et me retourne sur nrj12 pas posé
arena phobique expliquez-nous ce que
souhaitait psychorigide avec le sable
vous tombez sur le sable et moi j'adore
images et l'idée de dette sur une plage
bétonné ou un ponton voilà c'est tout
juste pour ça ouais ah oui voix
suffisant si les chars à la montagne il
est surtout et touchent peu de sable
rose mais moi j'adore les plages merci
et au niveau des commandes au niveau de
l'intérim